el regreso a la unión europea o la
permanencia en reino unido- determinan
unas elecciones escocesas consideradas
como las más importantes en décadas el
partido nacional escocés de la ministra
principal nicola sturgeon apuesta en los
comicios no sólo la reelección de su
líder sino también la mayoría absoluta
su principal objetivo solicitar a
londres un nuevo referendo de
autodeterminación
el llamado no pasa desapercibido en una
sociedad altamente polarizada ayer no
quería salir de europa soy
fundamentalmente europea y nos dijeron
la última vez que votamos a nuestra
gente se le dijo que si votaban para
quedarse no saldrían de europa y lo
hicimos y eso está mal bandas
preferiría que preferiría un partido
útil
así que ya sabes por un nuevo thor ya no
olvido dijo en 2014 los escoceses
votaron 55% a 45% por quedarse en reino
unido sin embargo tras el break sheet el
ímpetu nacionalista se ha fortalecido de
ganar
el snp deberá solicitar permiso a
londres para realizar nuevamente la
consulta algo a lo que se niega al
primer ministro británico posición son
además el partido conservador escocés
hace una feroz campaña por bloquear ese
intento de salida mientras otras fuerzas
como los verdes hacen su propia apuesta
por el separatismo otros temas también
determinan la agenda entre éstos
destacan las propuestas para la
transición energética hacia una economía
más verde u otros como la reactivación
económica tras la pandemia y nuevos
programas de salud y educación